Jumanji the next level is packed with
action and jokes with plenty to keep
even the child with the shortest
attention span happy there's also plenty
of stuff to keep older viewers engaged
and asking questions these are some of
the things that only adult moviegoers
will notice in Jumanji the next level
but beware there are spoilers ahead it's
not hard to wonder who Jumanji the next
level thinks its audiences the film's
marketed as a family film after all it's
central protagonists are teenagers and
the action revolves around a video game
with lots of jokes and action sequences
to fill out the running time there's a
romantic subplot involving Martha and
Spencer two warring friends resolve
their differences and every character
learns a little about themselves yes
like its predecessor there's a little
something for everybody in Jumanji the
next level a little too much hit viewers
may marvel at the dazzling array of
treats on offer that adults may be
puzzled as to who exactly this movie is
for it's a kids movie but the kids in it
are college-age so then they're actually
adults coming to terms with aging is a
major theme Danny DeVito's Eddy learns
that growing old isn't a burden but
rather a gift and he goes back into the
workforce after 15 years of fuming over
his business partner selling his
restaurant that's not exactly something
kids can relate to but then older adult
viewers who would get all that probably
don't care too much about the inner
workings of video games it takes a while
for Jumanji the next level to get going
which is to say to get the young quartet
of friends into the video game world and
into the skins of their movie star
avatars the long first act of the movie
catches up the audience on what Bethany
Spencer fridge and Martha have been up
to since they were last seen in Jumanji
welcome to the jungle in short they've
all graduated high school and moved away
Martha is in college phryges to Bethany
does charity work and Spencer works a
dreary job in a Manhattan pharmacy they
all reconnect when they come home for
the holidays or at least they try to
still talking to their friends
it's complicated when we first got
together
we were different people Spencer doesn't
show up for a scheduled brunch and the
other three realized he's been
increasingly out of touch in recent
months this is a pattern older viewers
know all too well one naturally grows
apart from their tight circle of
high-school and hometown friends Kidd
viewers may not quite understand or
believe that they won't be best friends
forever with their childhood BFFs but
Jumanji the next level makes it clear
why that happens these four people who
live in different parts of the country
following different paths don't have
very much in common with each other on
the surface it's a movie about video
games and celebrity impersonations
but Jumanji the next level surprisingly
and effectively explores a number of
psychological truths most of which kids
just wouldn't understand because they
simply haven't lived long enough to
relate Spencer is full-on depressed he
feels like his life is going nowhere and
because of that is too ashamed to see
his more successful friends it's a
mindset that already led him to split
with his girlfriend Martha many people
have this type of existential crisis
after high school the sense of not
knowing what to do or where to go next
and feeling like a failure because of it
particularly astute audience members may
think that Spencer feels he peaked
already after all he's likely never
going to have a life experience that
comes close to matching living inside a
deadly video game Rory McCann joins the
world of Jumanji with his role as the
terrifying villain of Jumanji the next
level a power-mad aptly named warrior
king named Jurgen the brutal McCann is
most recognizable to audiences and
primarily to the adults in the audience
for his work on Game of Thrones as the
equally intimidating Sandor Clegane aka
the Hound you don't seem to understand
the situation I understand this if any
more words come pouring out your mouth
I'm gonna have to eat every King chicken
in this room juergen the brutal
ultimately isn't all that far removed
from the Hound
as Jumanji the next level includes a few
clever references to McCann's late great
HBO series early in the film
you're gonna slank by a pair of massive
bloodthirsty hyenas they're very shaggy
and not in
instantly recognizable as that
particular wild animal they actually
look more like big dogs or in Thrones
parlance direwolves dressed in furs and
sulking around a castle half the time
juergen sometimes looks like he's
cosplaying as Jon Snow
but then the film gives a shout-out to
his old Game of Thrones character
juergen battles to the death with dr.
smolder brave stone on an airship at one
point brave stone jumps on to uragan
sending them both falling that's just
like the way the Hound jumped onto his
brother the mountain during their epic
battle that resulted in both of their
deaths
Jumanji the next level is dark and full
of terrors from video games to quality
television kids have a variety of
entertainment options at their disposal
but at the end of the day most of them
are going to wind up watching the same
movie a true classic fervently beloved
by all the children of the world in the
year 2019 Lawrence of Arabia the 1962
historical epic about British military
leader TE Lawrence that won the Academy
Award for Best Picture yeah now we're
totally kidding kids today aren't into
Lawrence of Arabia
nor were kids into the movie when it was
first released however it's an indelible
classic of a film and at least two of
its elements became cultural touchstones
cinematographer freddy young's sweeping
beautiful shots of desert landscapes and
more ecr's regal rousing score Jumanji
the next level features many desert
scenes providing the opportunity for a
visual reference to Lawrence of Arabia
in the form of an extra-wide shot more
mature film goers will likely understand
these allusions especially since the
Jumanji score emphasizes it with musical
motifs that hint at the Lawrence score
there are very few kids on earth who
would smile and chuckle at these
highbrow references check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]